bienvenidos y gracias por acompañarme en
esto que yo llamo un viaje de la mente
la postura y la respiración hacen una
enorme diferencia en la meditación
así que antes de comenzar si aún no
estás en una silla cómoda y firme con tu
espalda erguida pausa este vídeo y ve a
buscar esa silla firme y cómoda con un
respaldo recto y un lugar que de
preferencia sea más o menos silencioso y
tranquilo
ya que estás ahí siéntate e intenta
poner tus pies bien plantados en el piso
cuando yo medito me gusta apoyar las
manos sobre los muslos con las palmas
hacia arriba relajadas sin ningún
esfuerzo
ahora comienza a respirar lentamente
un poco más profundo que como lo estabas
haciendo y un poco más lento
inhala
y exhala
a tu propio ritmo pero un poco más
profundo y un poco más lento
si lo prefieres a algunas personas les
gusta inhalar por la nariz y exhalar por
la boca
pero la clave nuevamente es hacerlo un
poco más profundo
y un poco más lento
mientras lo haces comienza a relajar tu
mirada si aún tienes los ojos abiertos y
cuando te sientas cómodo cierra los
suavemente
antes de entrar al centro de la
meditación quiero recordarte algunas
cosas
todo este ejercicio se trata de explorar
tu ser interior
de curiosidad
de relajación
no hay una manera perfecta de meditar
algunas personas a veces piensan que no
lo están haciendo bien o que su mente
está demasiado inquieta y eso les
produce estrés y eso es lo opuesto de lo
que debería de ser la meditación debe de
ser placentera incluso puede ser
divertida a ratos debe producir te
curiosidad
debes disfrutarla
si de pronto hay distracciones e
inevitablemente habrá podrán ser ruidos
a tu alrededor o alguna parte de tu
cuerpo que te pica no permitas que te
estrés en solo acepta las son parte del
universo son solo átomos haciendo lo que
tienen que hacer es el universo haciendo
lo suyo
y no te preocupes si necesitas rascarse
o ajustar alguna parte de tu cuerpo no
hay razón para estresarse
ahora
para sumar a la idea de que esto no
debería de ser una experiencia
estresante te voy a pedir que hagas algo
que puede o puede no sentirse demasiado
natural
te voy a pedir que sonrías
regálate una buena sonrisa
con los ojos cerrados simplemente sonríe
obviamente sonreímos cuando estamos
felices pero muchas veces sonreír nos
hace un poquito más felices
puede hacernos sentir un poco menos
estresados
y entonces aunque tengas que forzarlo un
poco sonríe
y mientras hacemos esta meditación tanto
como sea posible mientras no tengas que
esforzarte demasiado
intenta conservar una ligera sonrisa en
tu rostro todo el tiempo muy bien vamos
a comenzar algo que debes tener en mente
mientras empiezas a calmar tu mente es
simplemente agradecer que estás vivo que
estás en este gran misterio que llamamos
vida que estás haciendo una pausa para
apreciar quién que eres verdaderamente y
la belleza de este misterio esta
existencia este universo que compartimos
mientras respiras más profunda y
lentamente
con los ojos cerrados intenta estar más
consciente de tus pensamientos en que
estás pensando
pensamientos aislados
algo que viste en la televisión
algo que pasó en la escuela
estás pensando en algún examen que debes
presentar
o en alguien de la escuela en que sueles
pensar mucho
solo observa tus pensamientos no pelees
con ellos
solo observarlos
y mientras observas comienza a darte
cuenta de que no eres tus pensamientos
eres algo distinto de tus pensamientos
ellos están en tu cabeza contigo pero
claramente los puedes observar
puedes verlos pasar
algunas veces puedes perderte en ellos
pero creo que estás viendo ahora mismo
que tú no eres tus pensamientos
en efecto puedes observar tus
pensamientos algunas personas usan la
metáfora de que los pensamientos son
autos en una calle bueno en autopista y
frecuentemente estamos en medio de la
autopista
y estos autos nos bombardean
nos golpean
de alguna forma debemos esquivar los nos
abruman
y para observarlos algo que debemos
hacer es salir de la autopista
no debes pelear con los pensamientos
estos autos van a seguir pasando
pero ahora que estás en la orilla
ya no estás en la autopista
puedes verlos pasar
y lo que a menudo va a suceder mientras
observas tus pensamientos es que
comienzan a ser más lentos
si eso sucede si comienzan a pasar más
lentamente maravilloso aprovéchelo
comienza a darte cuenta cómo te sientes
cuando los pensamientos son más lentos
e incluso habrá momentos en los que no
tengas pensamientos en la siguiente
respiraciones inténtalo
intenta no tener pensamientos
solo inhala
y exhala
sin pensamientos
solo tranquilidad
solo tu conciencia aquí en este universo
no hay tiempo
no hay espacio
todo está en tu mente
sin pensamientos
tranquilidad
mientras intentas conservar ese estado
tu mente inevitablemente va a deambular
vas a comenzar a pensar en una tarea que
tienes que entregar pronto
vas a pensar en algo que tienes que
hacer este fin de semana o en alguien en
quien piensas demasiado
eso está bien no seas duro contigo si tu
mente deambula solo recuerda
lentamente regresa e intenta volver a la
tranquilidad piensa o mira me distrajo
un momento comencé a pensar en algo es
gracioso pero voy a traer a la
tranquilidad de nuevo a mi mente
voy a intentar desacelerar estos autos
y suavemente inhala
y exhala
te voy a dar unos minutos para que
permanezca sentado tranquilo
inhalando
y exhalando
en calma con tus pensamientos
si tu mente deambula no hay problema
solo trata de regresar cuando puedas y
si el silencio te empieza a molestar un
poco no te preocupes te aseguro que
volveré en unos minutos
ahora que tuviste un poco de tiempo para
ti mismo
te voy a dar algunas ideas que pueden
ayudarte a valorar quién eres realmente
muchas veces nos atrapa el día a día y
empezamos a preocuparnos por las
calificaciones o las cosas que dejamos
pendientes por lo que la gente piensa en
nosotros pero recuerda tú no eres eso
no te definen los resultados de tus
exámenes no te definen tus
calificaciones no te define lo que la
gente piensa de ti eres pura conciencia
te asocias con tu cuerpo con tus
pensamientos pero son sólo parte de ti
no son tú
tú eres algo más profundo eres algo
mucho más grande piensa en lo vasto que
es el universo no sólo vasto en espacio
sino en tiempo
eso pone muchos de nuestros problemas en
perspectiva dentro de 100 años
dentro de mil años serán igual de
importantes estos problemas cuando
piensas en tu lugar en el planeta como
parte del cosmos
son igual de importantes estos temas
te voy a dar unos momentos más para
pensar en estas ideas para pensar en la
vastedad del universo y en el privilegio
de poder ser parte de él
de ver su belleza y en lo pequeñas que
realmente son algunas cosas que a menudo
nos definen
entonces ahora cuando te sientas cómodo
lentamente con los ojos cerrados
comienza a sentir y escuchar poco a poco
la habitación que te rodea
ponte un poco más en contacto con tu
cuerpo y cuando estés listo
abre los ojos
y toma estas ideas llévate la
tranquilidad contigo por el resto de tu
día y agradece te a ti mismo por tomarte
el tiempo para hacer esto hoy y te
invito a hacer de esto una práctica
quizás puedas no creer lo que pueden
hacer unos cuantos minutos de meditación
por mí pero te aseguro
si lo haces un día sí y un día no si
haces de esto una práctica si lo haces
regularmente en unas semanas unos
cuantos meses vas a notar algunos
cambios vas a ver que estarás más
abierto a la experiencia verás más la
belleza en muchas cosas vas a tener una
energía positiva con la que la gente va
a querer conectarse que va a atraer a la
gente
y verás que te irá mejor en algunas
cosas de las que hablamos antes
porque ya no te van a estresar más las
vas a disfrutar estarás haciendo lo que
puedas pero no te vas a pegar al
resultado
haces lo que puedes y que suceda lo que
tenga que suceder está bien
si las cosas no resultan como querías
está bien acepta las cosas como son y
luego decides qué otras acciones puedes
tomar organiza tus acciones una por una
para poder obtener otro resultado
pero una vez más
si el resultado es el que buscabas
maravilloso
si no lo es acéptalo y avanza desde ahí
te dejo con nuestra meditación gracias
por unirte y de nuevo gracias por
tomarte un tiempo para ti mismo